ECD O SERVED
COSER TRUMP
IMPEACHMENT.
I O SHOW A CLIP JUST
POSTED ON UTN
TO  SO THEY CAN WINN
ELEC.'SDOG
OF THE OTHER THINGTHE OVER THE N
I'M INNOANWEILE THAT VOUNDLY.
>> ACHARGES. HONIG, MA HABERWA
REPORTING CONSPIRACY TO
OBSTCT, FALSSTATEMENTS.
>> ANDICATINTING SHE JUST R.FIR
T RETENTIO
CH.
S NOALL OBSTRUCTN.HAD BEE QUEST
OBRUCASE?
ACCOS REPORTING
THERE IS A DN
OBSTRUCTIOS NOT ALABN.
'SNDBSTRUCTION.
MAGGIE ALSREEDT
ARE THE SAME.
YO IFE
INDINTCOTSE OUNTS OFT CETERA.
THIS TELLS US THAT THE ACCORDIN
REPORTING, SEVEN DIFFERE
CONSPIRACY FROM PRIOR REPORTING.
TES  OBSTRUCTION
COA LS COUNT.
N S CAMP
ABOUT MAAUTHORIZED THEFALSSTT PM
GG YOU WER
WHITENDENT COUNSAT DO YOU MAKEO
>>S
THE LT THEY WERE S BECAUSE I TE
LY HAVE
BEEN BROUGHTUTHERN
STF FLORIDA.
SO INKE
RST INWOD
>> PROBABLY THE OBSTRUCTION, N
LDAV
HAPPENED IN MAR-A-LAGO, THATINP
PARTARE
PT CHARGE CE
OUAND THEN I THINKO THAT
IS BECAUSE IT IS IUTRIIDA, A IA
MAR-A- WOULDCHEDULED IN  IIN WO
M A PALM C
JUL D E ASSIGNED
TO THAT PARTICULAR.
>> WHY IS AUSEE THE
CRIME IS ALLHAN PLACU WOULD REE
TO WHERERG IS LOCATED
D ERE THE.
HEAS A RIGHT TA JURY THACATION.
N HAPPENS TO WELL, INK
JURI
CRITICAL TO
THE JURY POOL IS
THE CHARGEITICAL.
ASE HA,
THIS IJUSTE OF, OF
HUNT BE SERIS.THG.A JURYW THATST
S TRYING TO
MAKE HR IT'S ON CIAL OR WITH HIO
I HAVE A FRIEN METITH
ERDAY IN BEDMINSTER.
HE IS NORR
WHATSOEVER.
I
S RESOLUTE.G HI WNOCENT.
THIS IH HUNTRE ITH
THERE ISOING TO  FA HER THE COUH
G TO
COME DOWLDE NEXT FEW YS.
NGGEAY
WITH, TH PUBLIC
N CAL .
AND HIS BASEND HUPPORTERS
ARG TO SUPPORTIM HE GOING
TO BELIE H
DOUBLING ANDE WILL BE
REDENED
THIS.
AND WHEN THIS COMES DOWNTHY ARMO
>> SWIFTNDM ON DONAL
>>T'E SO
SW THETORIC NATURE OF THIS, YOU
.I FINDT HARDE
HOW THERE IS A T
HESEESS WHAT
ONE WOULD ORDINARILY E
D AN ELECTION , WHIC
THE CHARGES ARE SERIOUS GH, THES
WOULDN'T THINK THIS WOULD BE A
THREE-DAY TRIAL.S LIKELYO BE A
E-.I CANNOTGITITUTION WHERE THEN
IS RUIS THLISENT, AND
HAA PRENHE IS GOIN TWO KSCOUR T
2024, ON TOPE
MANHN''S CASE IS
ANOTHER PROBABLY TWO
THWEJUST W
GO HAVE TWO TRIALS
WE HAVE A TRIAL DATE IE E WITHHK
TAN CASEATMARCH, MARCH
th TAKE YOU INTOO E TIMER EACH .
NO WAY THAT E THATS  THAT.
YOU WOULD HAVE TJANUARY OR FEBR.
THERE IS GOING TO OLUMINOUS
NOSAYINGE
MARCH INTO APRIL, YOU CAN'T
HAVELS AS  SAID.VE A CONSTITUTN
AW ACTPRESIDENALIGHNVHS
ELECTION?
IF A'T  THIN
WITH DOJ P ALSO STRAC  IN
ELECTED PRESIDENT, THEN WHAT
THS SE FIRF
CASE,  CONTROLS THE JUSTICE
HE JUSSMISSES THE -- I'SL NDE DH
IT'S GONE.
>> COULDN'T HE PARDOF?
>> WS A DEBATE
NDING
E THSTATES
BEHIND
ATN WED IS C HAD WITH DONALD TR.
>> OH, I'M SURE THATIGHT.
HAHE IS S THINND
NKS HE IS GOING TO GET
AWAY WIT.
O EVIS WATCHING THIS, NOWHAT'S .
REPUBLANYI T
JOBIING TO D
THIS.IAL PROSECUTOR.
THISA POTHING.'T THE
THAT HAS GAMED THIS THING OUH I
IF THAT'WHAPPENING HERE,
HIVERY,
SLY.
>> AND I THINK PEOPLE .
LE AROUND TH TOFE  DO.T ALICE AR
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIBE
TALKING TO OUR FRIENDS.
THE RIGHT, THEY WANTTHE
FBI.
THEY DON'T TRUST THEBI
THEY DON'T TRUST ANY O
DEE ID IT  NOT G
HEGOY Y.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE A BIG RALLY
IN GEORGIA, NORTH CAROLINAENE S
LL LOO Y OUTSIDE MIDA
REME T BROOKRI I
>> TO ME WHEPARITO HAPPEON
CONSTITUALRVATIVESD
AT A CERTAIN, PEOPLEAVE
O20 LE OF . A REASON FOR THE
TH NOT THE NORMAL --
LISTENIF T A
THINNDLED IN
RIATE WAY, TRY LONG TIME TO  THE
E STAND BY WHILE PEOPLE RUNNINL
NG INTE
GROUND OUR SOCIETY.
L PROJS BEEN TWSS  W
AND UTIONS, THE MEDIA, TO DISQU
ABLE TO MAKUALI THE JDE
THE CASE WTHHI A SYSTEM.
TAKEUP WILL THEY
I SUSPT AMONHI
GOAP
I GUESS,
AFTER IST
ANNOUNCED, JIM
AND WE'LL SEE WHAT HPE A Y FOR C
HOUSE REIC O TE OF
THE JUSTICE PA THIS IS ESPIONAGN
TEG  WILEAT ON JANUARY 6th.D THA
LOOSE, WHETHER IT L HAVE HELLIN
FLASHING D
MOREOTE
SUFFICIENT FOR MANY, BUT DERSTA.
BUT HE WIL PROCESS.
HE W. IN
MIAMI COURTHOUSE TO ANSWER THE
FEDERAL CHARGES NEXTS NOT IGNORS
HE T PROCESS
BEFORE THE MANS
IS HAS THE RIGHT TPROSECUTION,.